[Music]
[Music]
hey you guys yeah we're a little bit
later today yeah i think later is better
we're trying to decide we're like
sitting here going yeah because
for a while like i said we moved
everything to five because
we said oh it'd be easier for everybody
to remember instead of like three three
three sometimes three seven five yeah
but yeah then when you were saying uh
because we've been doing this matinee
shows at five and you're like well
there's really not that many people
showing up for them and i was like maybe
it's just because people in the at least
in this time zone are
commuting home from work and they're not
home yet so maybe we should like push
them back push things back to like six
or seven because you already got a
pretty good crowd in there
maybe it's just the word whorehouse and
the title that brought everybody
let me give them a drink i left my drink
in the room okay yeah so uh so we told
you yes we actually hadn't decided
because we were doing like the the burt
reynolds trifecta this week we've done
like a lot of burt reynolds movies now
that i'm thinking about it but
we hadn't decided which one we were
gonna do last night so we were like
scrolling through all the offerings on
amazon prime and they have uh an
alarming number of burt reynolds movies
on there not all of which are free most
of them you had to pay for but that's
okay
and uh so we're going we were gonna do
stick
and then i don't know we were scrolling
through and tom's like i don't know i
kind of feel like more in the mood for
like a fun comedy and i was like well do
you want to do best little whorehouse in
texas which actually i had seen i saw
that a bunch of times like back on cable
back in the 80s i feel like the best
little whorehouse in texas was on cable
all the time back in the 80s i never saw
it this is the first time i saw it it's
pretty good
it's a music it's a musical so don't get
like i mean it's based on an actual like
broadway
musical we've said many times on the
shows that that we we love musicals i'm
the only straight man that likes me at
school well maybe not the only straight
man
or like i said one of the only straight
men that will admit he likes musicals
i like musicals now we're not talking
about something as slick as uh
as greece or you know but it's close i
mean it's it's taking place in texas
so it's got kind of a [ __ ] country
country kind of a [ __ ] motif to it
although there is like rock and
classical in it too but it's it
it's good it's a good movie it's a good
movie a lot of [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] boobs in it
you got dolly parton who is a southern
girl
well i'mma call it she was a girl in the
movie she's a southern woman of
legendary proportions
and you will not be disappointed
yeah that's the gravity-defying food she
had in there yeah every time she was in
a scene top kept saying tom kept saying
look at that it's amazing everyone's
amazing yeah that woman is amazing i
said jim we're going to get you a bra
i was like jenny how much of that do you
think is bra and how much is that his
boob
she looks great and there's a lot of
good she's a great actress my people
don't realize that [ __ ] she could act
and um
unlike some of these other movies that i
was talking about well you know the
southern accents are accurate her her
southern accent isn't accurate it's real
that's the real thing
everybody in our fail the women in our
family sound like this
that same high-pitched kind of tone and
just the banter between her and um
and [ __ ] her boyfriend who's played
by [ __ ]
bert reynolds it's like oh man you know
that's that's the way [ __ ] everybody
talks that's the way people really talk
you're talking about [ __ ] ufos and
jesus that one long scene i kind of love
that one long scene
where they just kind of like go up to
the bluff or whatever they're like to
look at the stars they go up there with
like a 12-pack and they're just like
kind of hanging and like talking to one
another yeah and it's just it's
delightful like the it just seems like a
very like natural conversation that they
have like i said going from like ufos to
talking about jesus and yeah it's like
really really who is jesus
[Laughter]
so yeah
he was a great speaker a great
entertainer
but yeah this came out in 1982
now it was based on the broadway play
which uh had first come out in 1978
as far as i'm aware i haven't seen the
broadway play but the plot is pretty
similar i think the only thing that's
different is maybe the ending is
slightly different and i think in the
play
um
they only uh you know dolly and burt's
characters
mona and uh what's his name uh ed earl
uh those two just had a one night stand
like a long time ago whereas in the
movie they kind of like see each other
all the time they're like they're a
regular item yeah they're kind of like
not boyfriend girlfriend exactly but
they are kind of sort of you know kind
of cheating with her
yeah girlfriend well see i don't think
that other woman they didn't really make
that clear i think that he didn't i
think what happened because he says to
her he says to dolly parton at one point
i know their characters have names but
you know um he says to dolly parton at
some point he's like i haven't slept
with another woman
for three years
so he's not sleeping with that other
woman he's just he's just dating her and
i think that well because remember when
they have that argument near the end and
dolly parton says to him you're just
using that other woman and her kid is
like a pretend family and you don't have
to like make a commitment to them right
you know because you you know you you're
not sleeping with her you don't live
with them you're not married to her you
know you just whenever you want family
stuff like he says oh he's he spends
thanksgiving over there every year and
[ __ ] like that so he just wants that
like but without having to commit to
that other woman dom deluise is in this
does some amazing performance
uh dom deluise was uh dude from brooklyn
uh he went to he went to tufts
university i lived on the tufts campus
for a while when i got out of the army i
lived there for a few months right
across the street from tufts university
he had a girlfriend that went there
and
he
he he's
he was spurt reynolds real-life friend
he can do a southern accent though he
sounds southern but he's not he's he's
from brooklyn he's italian okay
but he's [ __ ] he understands it
it's it's a great movie the movie's good
and they point that out in the movie
he's he he's playing this
[ __ ]
busybody who's a consumer advocate who
wants to get this whorehouse shut down
he's on television
and he's [ __ ] god he's talking about
he's i can tell when somebody's fake and
when somebody's not who they say they
are and he [ __ ] is putting on a damn
corset stuffing a big [ __ ] sock down
his pants to make his [ __ ] junk look
bigger did he put on a wig and
everything yeah he has like a wig it's
like a little lord follower yeah and he
goes away he's and he's speaking in a
[ __ ] c he's speaking in a super
southern accent talking about the
southeast where are you from then you go
you go because i'm from brooklyn no new
jersey new jersey he's in new jersey
you're from new jersey yeah he said new
jersey he wasn't there was nothing real
about him he wasn't even from the south
the character it's it's just a great
it's great and like the texas clothes
that he wears he wears like he's really
over-the-top like
glittery like cowboy and a wig and a wig
and stuff it's like really funny yeah
he's like a really like over the top
over the top fake a fake texan yeah it's
a fake texan so yeah that's kind of you
know what um the whorehouse in this
which is called the chicken ranch yeah
is based on a real place yeah uh there
was a place in lagrange texas
that was opened i believe in the early
20th century 1905 1910 something like
that
and it stayed open until the early 1970s
i think it closed in 73 or 74. and all
the stuff that they say in here like the
the um narration about the place where
it's like you know during the depression
or whatever they took payment and
chickens and so that they had so many
chickens that's absolutely true that's
why it ended up being called chicken
ranch they just bartered
yeah so um so that's why so all this all
the kind of like lore about this place
is even though this is set in gilbert
texas the actual chicken ranch was in
lagrange it's not there anymore right
but that it was based on a real place so
yeah now the director for this
interestingly was colin higgins this was
the last film that he directed he also
uh directed nine to five which dolly
parton was also in of course i think it
came out a couple years before this
and foul play do you remember that one
that was chevy chase and goldie hawn
yeah and i think burgess meredith was in
that too i remember really really liking
that movie i saw it like a bunch of
times back on came back on cable in the
day but i haven't seen a long time he
also colin higgins also uh wrote the
screenplay for harold and maude which is
one of my very favorite movies of of the
era
uh so there's that but yeah so jim
neighbors is in this too yeah pretending
to be straight [ __ ] gomer
he's kind of like well he's uh deputy
fred or as we called him cockblocker
friends yeah maybe he cocked blocks
because there was like a running gag
that like every time burt reynolds and
dolly parton were getting ready to like
get down to some business like deputy
fred would show up at the house being
like you know to chief you gotta like
sheriff you gotta go someplace you know
what i mean so because a lot of plugs
for frederick's of hollywood in this
movie well there was that one scene
where she like bought a bunch of stuff
yeah frederickson wasn't it frederick's
yeah yeah
yeah
where she had like she had bought all
this stuff
and then well that that extended scene
where she had bought herself all this
really nice stuff and like you know
dressed up all in it and she bought him
a pair of what they called a japanese
slingshot yeah
these little like black panties with
like silver snaps on the side for easy
removal so uh so she bought him those
and he was like the biggest baby about
like putting them on even though she had
bought like this big elaborate like
outfit with like stockings and coursing
and all these others and he's just like
oh
i just absolutely put his little panties
on or nothing like that
she finally i don't even think it was i
think it was more like like booty shorts
or like yeah
yeah and it's it was just funny because
and then like he he finally like danes
to put them on and then he runs through
the room so fast it like jumps out of
the blanket that she couldn't even see
it yeah
that was just like funny that scene was
like super funny
but yeah so a story story behind it like
i said they kind of had this
whorehouse which like you know
technically illegal
but it was kind of legendary everybody
knew about it everybody was just kind of
like that's an institution you know back
in the world war one like guys went
there and then when world war ii came
along they took their sons there and
like it was just this big thing and
there's like a big thing later with uh
those two college football teams and
it's like whoever wins like the
thanksgiving game like they all like
their coach like their coach like treats
them to a party there so it's kind of
like this institution even though
technically like i said it's illegal but
everyone's just kind of like looking the
other way and everything is working out
fine until
dom deluise's character his his
character name is melvin thorpe right
yeah i think yeah he's kind of like this
you know tv so he's kind of like you
know like geraldo or something like that
yeah where he's just kind of like wants
to expose things just to cause like
outrage
so he kind of has this like ridiculous
tv show with like backup dancers and
everything like that where uh so he
wants to he's trying to like moralize
about this uh about this place and so
he's trying to get bert reynolds like
the sheriff to
you know admit that he's like taking
bribes to keep it open and [ __ ] like
that which he's not and so that's kind
of where the problem starts as he keeps
getting involved and then burt reynolds
probably doesn't
help matters when he gets like really
upset at the dude and like
yeah screams at him on camera and like
shoots his gun in the air and stuff like
that does not have a singing role in
this he sings a little bit
much on the one well he now
i think initially um
they were gonna i think initially they
were gonna get uh somebody else for this
but then
um when they got bert
that was part of his contract he said
well i want to sing
okay so the one song that they did in
the whole fredericks of hollywood scene
uh which was actually it was not in the
broadway play that was an original song
that dolly parton wrote for the movie
sneaking around i think it's called yeah
sneaking around with you
yeah yeah yeah um right yeah so he
wanted to sing so he's saying he sings a
little bit on that
but that's i think that's the only time
he sings
now the dude that plays the governor he
was in a bunch of [ __ ] i think didn't he
also play the uh the dude baron
harkonnen from from from from dunedin
that the same guy um no that's uh he
just looked kind of similar yeah that's
i can't remember his name i don't think
it's the same guy and you would never
he's he's been in a bunch of uh i think
he he's been in a bunch of burt reynolds
movies well he was in the last one
he was the head of the vice squad yeah
in sharky's machine he plays the
governor charles erning he [ __ ] sings
a whole song and dance numbered it's
[ __ ] hilarious he's good about
sidestepping about sidestepping
sidesteps because when they ask him
questions he's always kind of like
stepping over there instead of like not
answering him stepping to the side when
the media asks some questions he sighs
it's just a funny song well the scene
originally you know what's see this is
what happens when you like start
researching movies you find out all kind
of fun [ __ ] originally for that role
they wanted mickey rooney who obviously
you know song and dance guy but burt
reynolds convinced them he's like no i
think you should get charles derning
because you know yeah mickey rooney's
awesome but everybody knows he can sing
and dance yeah nobody knows charles
durden can sing and dance and it'll seem
like you discovered it you know what i
mean so so that's right because i didn't
know that charles turner could say
yeah he was good but yeah yeah that's
like a funny he just he just has one
song but yeah he does it's like toward
the end but yeah that's super funny yeah
um this actually it's interesting
because so because this had whorehouse
in the title
obviously this is 1982. so you're going
to run into some problems
in some states
so a lot of newspapers wouldn't print
ads or had to like censor it or had to
call it something else
uh i've seen it called the best little
cat house in texas
uh best little chicken house in texas
um some of the ads they just like
bleeped it yeah it was like it's really
stupid but yeah i well i remember
because i remember when this came out i
think i probably saw this when i was
probably 11 or 12
and i remember like being really
scandalized because a little kid and i
was being really scanned i was like oh
my god they're sharing a movie that says
whorehouse at the title that's amazing
and it's like you know what i mean
because it seemed like a dirty word back
then because i was a little kid but you
know what i mean
but yeah so there was a kind of a
problem about that
and uh you know so i guess some of um
some of dolly parton's maybe fans
weren't
didn't really like it all that much
although it didn't stop the movie from
being a massive [ __ ] hit it was the
highest grossing uh musical comedy of
that year the live action went anyway
and actually i think it was the fourth
highest grossing movie that year yeah
you know so
yeah it did really well it made like 70
million dollars yeah bob's saying they
couldn't make a light-hearted movie
about prostitution nowadays too much
welfare you're actually white right i
think you're actually white yeah
actually white yeah you actually write i
think
the uh
there's a lot of
it is a light-hearted movie and they do
kind of talk about it like what you know
like nothing's really dirty going on
here they're just you know i mean
everybody knows each other and there's a
bunch of rules you can't drink in here
and you know it's they talk about
nobody's complaining and they're paying
taxes they're just regular working
people
um and
and that they're they're giving they're
they're giving money to the [ __ ]
little league club so they could buy new
yeah uniforms
and they've been around forever and that
everybody likes miss mona who's played
by [ __ ] dolly parton and that she's a
good person and
nobody's nobody's really enforcing the
laws on them because it's been around
for so long because it has been there
it's back when that was legal so they're
just not really they're not gonna do
anything about it and and this when when
the movie starts off she's singing about
this is just a little piss out town in
texas this isn't anywhere
in in in in the main in the spotlight
you know what i mean it's that middle of
nowhere yeah it's kind of out in a
really rural area so you kind of have to
go like way out of town to go there
yeah i mean not anybody's face you have
to go out there to go find it yeah and
the thing about it too is that because
the place has such a reputation
and because it's always been run by just
like a madam who's always like really
nice to all the girls that work there
they don't allow pimp um yeah they don't
really allow any of that um and so it's
almost kind of got to a thing where
i mean nobody's really there against
their will necessarily you know what i'm
saying everybody's mad when they lose
their jobs yeah like everybody seems
like they're there for which like i said
you know yeah it's lighthearted making
lighthearted prostitution but honestly i
mean there's
there's you know uh there's brothels
legal brothels all over vegas and stuff
like that and you know in amsterdam and
other places like that i don't have a
problem with them as long as people
aren't like forced to work there if you
want to choose to work there then more
power to you and actually they kind of
um
it's interesting because they kind of go
into that in this movie too because burt
reynolds like as the sheriff he actually
goes to
the capitol he goes to houston or
whatever
he's gonna houston i don't remember he
goes to houston to like talk to the
governor
and you know he basically says you know
the girls aren't being forced to be
there it's like you know this is their
job it's their livelihood they pay
into the community and it's like it's a
community service and so
they're kind of like they go a little
bit into the whole like prostitution
legalization
uh issue not like so much that it's
heavy-handed but they do kind of like
bring it up and then and there's a lot
of southern characters in here give it
throwing their two cents in and it's
kind of across the board like one guy
thinks yeah we got to have this because
we saw these young men around here and
without this whorehouse they're going to
be out raping people yeah he says he
says
that was was that the same actor that
played like yeah yeah yeah
i seen that guy in everything
and then another guy was going like uh
he's like they'll just go around raping
me let's go around rave
and then another guy he's like he's like
yeah
i don't really you know i don't really
understand why they're so upset about
this you know
and and he goes in a way it's like
something from the past i mean where's
the whole sexual revolution went on
already we kind of don't need this
anymore just because you know there's no
people that all have sex anyway yeah so
there is so it tries to it
it gives a good um it gives a good um
like variety
of
southern opinions about prostitution
from those days
yeah and they're across the board and
very few people were condemning it the
guy that was contaminated wasn't from
the south he was a fake southerner well
and he didn't and he the the point of
the movie was he didn't really care
about it one way or the other he was
just doing it to get tv ratings yeah
it's about tv ratings because you care
yeah he didn't give a [ __ ] about it and
he didn't give a [ __ ] about
you know all the people that worked
there or because she had like a [ __ ]
ton of women working there oh yeah 20 of
them maybe god there was more i think it
was more than that yeah it was a lot it
was she had a very large staff
that house by the way which is it's
based on a real house like they built it
but it's one of the ones that's on the i
think it's on the universal back lot i
think that's the same house that they
used in a house of a thousand corpses
too okay
[Laughter]
which is kind of hilarious
when and now that i'm thinking about it
i was like oh yeah i thought that house
looked kind of familiar but yeah so i
just i don't know i thought it was like
kind of cool the songs are kind of are
kind of fun you know the one you know
what's crazy the one scene
where
all the football players the aggies
where they all come to the whorehouse
and all the women are dressed up in like
ball like prom gowns or ball gowns or
whatever they're trying to make it look
like a big college dance or whatever and
then like they whip all the skirts off
and they have the you know the you know
garter belts on and whatnot and so
they're like they're dancing with them
that scene reminded me very very
strongly of the prom scene from greece
yeah like some of the dance moves even
the song a little bit
um sound gave me a little bit of a hand
jive kind of not exactly but it kind of
sounds sort of like it yeah
and um yeah they used a lot of the songs
from the actual broadway play like i
said that sneaking around song was one
that dolly parton wrote and then they
used a little bit of i will always um
i will always love you yeah that big
song that she had jenny brought up
during the time we were watching because
a lot of people think that this is uh
that's a whitney he's it's a houston
song it's not it's dolly parton it's a
dolly parton song yeah yeah it came out
in 1970's
1974.
dolly can sing and she was always cute
all right you go back
and go look at her and listen to her her
falsetto was almost kind of like a yodel
that was a real old-school [ __ ]
country sound
and she was always cute
um you she admits that you know she had
boobs jobs she got bigger and bigger as
she went
and she's pretty big in this one yeah
and uh she still looks good for being
[ __ ] 70 something you know of course
there's nothing natural about that woman
you know she's totally man-made but she
looks great for her age
and uh well didn't she what is it one of
her famous quotes like um
it's really expensive to look this cheap
or something like that yeah
there's a [ __ ] great clip
where she goes on barbara water walters
barbara waters no walters walters walter
yeah barbara walters and barbara walters
this is back like in the early 80s tries
to humiliate her
you know it you could tell she was a
jealous [ __ ] man you know
barbara was [ __ ] jealous ever
basically tries to humiliate her
basically saying
you know you're poor you're uneducated
you're ignorant uh your boobs are fake
and you you got fake hair
and [ __ ]
dolly handles her [ __ ] well and when
you read the comments underneath [ __ ]
dolly came off [ __ ] smelling like a
rose and just looking like [ __ ] super
classy and [ __ ] barbara walters came
out looking like a [ __ ] evil jealous
[ __ ] behind that [ __ ] but [ __ ] i
remember that [ __ ] i went back and
saw that when i was listening to her
stuff earlier and i was just like god
damn man
[ __ ] man [ __ ] are mean man
dolly always seems [ __ ] class act she
seems like a delightful person and and
her like um
just i i really love like the whole
interaction between her and bert
reynolds in this they just seem like
they're having i don't know if this is
true but they seem like they're having
the time of their lives yeah they just
seemed like just very cheerful yeah and
just full of goodwill yeah and it just
seems like a really fun they seem like
they're just having a fun time like on
this fun ass valley was from virginia
wasn't she oh i don't know
i thought tennessee but i could be wrong
about that where is where is dollywood
i thought isn't dollywood in tennessee
i don't know am i completely crazy am i
just like i i can't even remember why
why i know that no i wasn't somebody who
goes kids was this soft core porn no it
was a softcore porn there was a point
there was a porn parody of it yeah um
there is like the worst that's in this
you're gonna see um boobs
and a bunch of asses male and female
yeah um no no junk far as i know no no
uh vag
it's mostly just boobs yeah
you know it's a lot of boobs yeah you
know uh dolly wears a lot of low-cut
stuff yeah which you know she's got to
well yeah that's kind of the whole but
you know yeah she has some pretty
fabulous outfits in this they are very
very this woman's amazing
i'm just kept saying that ever
it's amazing every time she was on
screen this woman's amazing amazing her
boobs were just like they were just like
defying gravity like i said and they put
her like in all these like really
glittery
very like those very like country like
fancy yeah outfits like super yeah like
very very
very very glittery yeah
very very low cut yeah um you know very
like hourglass yeah kind of like that
one red thing she wore was like pretty
awesome with like these big puffy like
sleeves i'm like i might wear that
nowadays yeah
she was a southern woman of epic
proportions
imaginary
yeah
dollywood is in tennessee yeah
okay that's where she's from then see i
was right about how did i know that i
don't know i was thinking virginia maybe
but probably because i think she was in
a movie where she played somebody for
jimmy about cole meyer's daughter or
some [ __ ] she would have coleman was
she in colombia that was sissies
basically she's basic yes i must i must
be for some reason i was thinking she
might have something to virginia so
tennessee right above mississippi yeah
i thought there was like some other i
had some other like uh facts down here
that this is kind of funny
so um
when you hear her voice that's it that's
the way
southern women from my childhood sounded
a lot of our my relatives still sound
like that
on my dad's side
um yeah there are probably still some
out there that sound like that i think
internet maybe got rid of a lot of that
accent but
that would that's the way they sounded
uh i don't think young people sound that
way anymore but that's that's the way
the southern accent sounded
yeah my my grandmother and her sister
who are from tennessee sounded like
dolly barton yeah and the pitch
southern women had a higher pitched
voice you know i did it out they did
it's like that they they were they were
always up here i'll come back now get
happening again
you know and oh you know you know i've
been real strong mars
stuff like that real strong rs but
that's
kind of retro you don't hear it in young
people today but that was you know my
generation and you and young and older
dolly had some great lines in this too
like some great like [ __ ] dialogue i
just really liked all the dialogue in
this it was like super funny yeah but
yeah so this is what uh bert reynolds
said because now this was 1982.
so burt reynolds had directed some
movies prior to this
um bert reynolds said that dolly had two
directors fired before we started
because i'd made so many movies and she
hadn't everyone thought it was me
he just thought it was funny that she
that she'd only been in like i think she
was in nine to five i think that was
1980 i want to say i kind of want to
watch that again that was like that was
jane fonda and lily tomlin and her um
because i haven't seen that in a really
long time either but i think it was
1980. so she'd been in that i don't know
if she was anything prior to that so
she'd only been in like one or two
movies up to now and then like she could
just come in and like fire the directors
like burt reynolds thought that was kind
of amazing but
he's like everyone thought it was me
because i had been in a bunch of movies
bob apple said barbara walters tried to
[ __ ] break richard pryor's balls too
he just gave her cold hard truth yeah
because [ __ ] prior had a [ __ ]
rough upbringing too he was born in a
whorehouse his mother was a prostitute
yeah and uh he's [ __ ] open about
his rough upbringing you know he was
rags to riches story and he made that
just on the back of [ __ ] sheer tower
and charisma
you know
and uh
[ __ ] only thing that was [ __ ] i
feel bad about prior is that he was a
huge fan of superman
and he grew up watching superman he
loved [ __ ] richard daughter superman
when he got a chance to be in superman 3
he was really disappointed with the way
that that one turned out he wanted it to
be just as epic as the first two
and i feel bad for prior though that
does make me really sad i don't know
that just makes me annoyed at least yeah
it kind of [ __ ] makes you kind of
[ __ ] go ugh
puts a lump up my throat that because he
he
he died later on but he wanted to
he wanted to he wanted superman three to
be as epic as one and two because he
grew up watching that he he said he
watched [ __ ] one and two just over
and over again he loved him
and he they wanted him to kill superman
in the original script he said i'm not
gonna kill superman absolutely not yeah
yeah what are you doing
yeah well that's the thing and what i
was gonna say was that or try to kill
superman what you kind of have to do and
i think like what what dolly was good at
doing and what some other like
celebrities are good at doing too is
that
if you have like somebody coming at you
like trying to like shame you for
something well you can't really have any
shame right you can't really have any
secrets you can't really have anything
you want to hide necessarily because
then that's something that they can use
against you
if you know if if they just come at you
saying like this that the other which is
funny because we were talking about a
scene in this movie like like i said
where uh where burt and dolly have like
a big argument because
she said that because of all the
brouhaha that she was gonna close down
the whorehouse just until everything
blew over and then she had forgotten
about this big like football party and
she's like well [ __ ] okay well we'll
just keep it open this one night and
then we'll shut it down and then burt
found out about it and got really mad
he's like you gave me your word they
were gonna shut it down so they have
this big fight
and then at the end of it like she's
like reading him the riot act even
though everything she says is right is
like correct and then he just calls her
a [ __ ] to her face
and
i'd have been like and she got really
upset but i'd have been like if it was
me i'd be like yep that's right yeah
she's like yeah i'm a horse that what
but uh but yeah so they they couldn't
have that because jesus says he said
that he was raised by his grandma yeah i
think he was but i thought he said his
mother was a hooker
richard pryor yeah
well i don't know i'd have to look so
that's how i remembered it that might be
it might be wrong but that's how i
remember it yeah zuzia said i love dolly
yeah i mean like i said she seems like
uh she seems like a delightful person
and she's cute as a button in this um
she is just like so funny and just so
cute and just like her boobs are just
like gravitating around about about
not having secrets
again um oscar wilde said uh if you've
got any skeletons in your closet you
better learn how to make them dance yeah
that's essentially that's that's just
like an can artistic money off of your
skeletons in your closet
and like i said then nobody can really
like attack you they can't attack you
because you've already like laid
everything out on the table and you're
not embarrassed about you're like yep
that's me
deal with that the skeletons in your
closet are what you're using to make
money
yeah that's you know
so you can't detect that
i want to say too another fun fact that
i learned about this movie was that like
i said it made a lot of money and was
kind of like the highest grossing
live-action musical uh of that year of
82 and
it was the movie that knocked e.t off
the number one spot easy had been number
one for six weeks
and this movie came out and knocked it
off like i said this made like 70
million dollars
yeah in 1982 that's like pretty good for
like a country music
musical about a whorehouse yeah back in
those days back in those days i mean
that's kind of like a big deal it was
like one of the highest grossing movies
that year and like i said i remembered
i hadn't seen it in probably 30 years at
least
but i saw it multiple times on cable
back in the old days probably when i was
i kind of feel like i was probably like
let's see if it came out in theaters in
1982 i was 10 years old i didn't see it
in the theater but it would have been on
cable like a year or two later so i
guess i would have been like 12 or
something like that when i first saw it
and i just saw it a bunch of times
because i feel like it was always on and
the guy that directed it his other movie
foul play he did nine to five too
his other movie foul play i feel like i
saw that even more times yeah and now
that i'm reminded about that i was like
now i kind of want to watch that again
because i remember liking that a lot it
was like a mystery story but funny like
a mystery comedy
with uh chevy chase in it and goldie
hawn
so i'm gonna have to that's that's what
i'm thinking of right i think so i'm
pretty sure
but this one it's good musical um it's
worth it's worth putting in the pile
with the other good musicals that you
watch regularly
um
i don't know if t seen it t likes t and
her husband they like musicals so i
might recommend it to her it's i'm not a
big fan of country music
oh yeah me neither but and this one here
the story is good enough
and the country songs are
they're they're kind of not your
hardcore country it's more of mass
appeal kind of country music it's just
the motif of the song
that fits the story
you know
uh so it makes sense in the context of
the story and what drives the with this
story is burnt dolly and dom de louise
drive this story
and it's the story more than anything
else uh
i think the story in the video yeah
because there's musicals and like
there's music and like dance numbers in
it yeah but a lot of it is
it's just dialogue
so like every now and then so i guess
it's kind of more like grease in that
way where it's like yeah they bust out
into song every now and then but a lot
of it is just like dialogue and story
and i think that's kind of like the
heart of it yeah it's a good mix yeah
it's a good mix of stuff yeah it's not
like one of those ones where like every
single thing is like singing yeah like
song song and song and song no yeah
they're pretty they're pretty like well
spaced i think yeah so if you don't like
country
you'd still like this that's what i'm
getting at i mean the songs are still
fun and they're his fun songs they're
just fun yeah they're just kind of like
you got funny lyrics and [ __ ] about
being hookers
funny songs about being a hooker yeah
yeah it's like an accent [ __ ] uh
you know getting in trouble and [ __ ]
uh songs about politicians who are
trying to side step questions you know
just
it's just good it's just a good story
yeah it's a yeah i had forgotten how
much fun this one was uh tammy said my
husband had an aunt and uncle that
worked in dollywood they said dolly was
as sweet in real life as she seems on tv
i've heard that over and over again i
have as well she seems like a lovely
human that she's a good person yeah
and um
got a good sense of humor and she's not
dumb
barbara waters tried to make her sound
like she was just this ignorant [ __ ]
trailer trash running around barefoot
you know i mean no you're so stupid it's
just boobs no evidently she's [ __ ]
very smart very [ __ ] cunning business
woman
and very i mean yeah i grew up in a
trailer park i walk around barefoot
and i have big boobs too yeah and i am
absolutely not done right jenny can
write whole [ __ ] books
and they're like uh
scholarly [ __ ] books about damn
[ __ ] forensics and [ __ ]
your background doesn't as me it doesn't
mean as much as people think it does a
lot of people are self-made well like i
said you just can't judge people
immediately until you like know that you
know what i'm saying you don't really
necessarily some people are just born
with good genes and they just [ __ ]
rise to their appropriate level that's
that's a lot of it
that's right
all right so
and the south had good genes it did
that's why a lot of us left
they come back though just depends on
what generation you're talking about
yeah yeah all right so i guess that'll
do it right yeah okay
so tomorrow night is the regular show
what time do you want to do it do you
want to do it at six or seven or what do
you want to do
oh tomorrow we did like six or so
let's okay let's do it at six and six or
seven whatever so then maybe i'll like
announce it tomorrow like what i'll do a
little bit later give people more time
so tomorrow night's the main show is
going to be episode 292
and overwhelmingly in the patreon poll
the one that won i kind of had a feeling
that this one was gonna win
are cold case updates now so we're going
to talk about like some missing persons
cases that we've covered on some of our
old shows that have had new developments
in them and there's also a couple of
murder cases that i had previously
talked about that have been solved or as
good as solved and i kind of wanted to
talk about those as well
so where that's what we're going to do
we're going to do cold cases solved and
updated and it'll be fun there's just a
bunch of cases that i have that i want
to talk about so that should be fun like
i said we'll probably do it at six
instead of five and we might just
like i said we might just move stuff
later because i do kind of feel like the
five o'clock
like a lot of people were missing them
because probably like i said at least
this time zone they're probably on their
way home from work and can't listen to
it so we'll wait a little bit longer
until everybody's home i know
everybody's in different time zones so
just but you you know we can't we just
like we can't we can't please everybody
so it's just kind of like we just got to
do what we got to do so uh yeah so
thanks for dropping by on our later show
this evening and we will see you guys
tomorrow evening
bye